the Bahamas is renowned for its
beautiful beaches sparkling seas and
increasingly it seems it's swimming
swine's pigs that love to paddle have
become an attraction all of their own
did they escape off of a shipwreck or
were they brought here hundreds of years
ago by pirates and explorers they are
truly one of nature's most amusing
accidents but cutis that all looks
animal rights activists have raised the
alarm they claim local businesses are
mistreating the pigs and exploiting them
for profit for example by throwing them
into the water for the amusement of
tourists Kim Arana from the Bahamas
Humane Society says it all comes down to
ignorance
I think the stupidity with the animals
is purely ignorance and we see the same
form of stupidity take place all over
the world we have seen many many video
clips of tourists trying to feed them
beer or rum we've seen pictures of
people trying to ride on their backs
throwing sand at the teasing them tour
operators offering the chance to swim
with pigs have defended their business
saying the animals are not harmed the
popularity of the original feral colony
has seen a host of other pig related
attractions spring up with the
authorities now promising to regulate
this side of the tourism industry
Kim Ohana again once greater oversight
people need to know how to behave around
them and they need to be careful and
there needs to be someone who is
watching and who can stop people from
behaving inappropriately and unless
there is adequate surveillance no I
don't think it can be stopped
there are no regulations here in the
Bahamas to protect the pigs from the
stupidity of humans
you